i'm not sure if you're okay talking
about this but
did you go through a period of time
where you were not able to pay your
bills
being a cinematographer oh yeah no i'm
happy to discuss that yeah yeah for sure
okay yeah i so i've been in los angeles
for 15
years 15 something like that and i've
was i've been broke for probably 11 of
them
10 something like that like
problematically broke
for you know five six years
and i feel very lucky this is this is
one of the things that i i'm always very
thankful for
is i always knew i wanted to be involved
in filmmaking
or at least from a very young age i i
didn't know if it was realistic
my mother wanted me to be a doctor my
whole family's doctors
except for me uh but i just
i was so i just loved it so much
filmmaking the idea of it and any little
taste i got
that i was can i slept in my car my last
semester of undergrad i slept in
my car i went to the gym in the morning
to shower like it was
it never felt and it kind of felt
romantic i never felt
[Music]
like i was sacrificing even though i
guess i
was it didn't feel that way because i
was pursuing this
kind of weird dream and it always
and money i will say you know it's
tricky if you if you're raising a family
and all that but
i for me it has
always served me well to ignore
money in the jobs i pursue
and all that i have friends who are um
who are doing well in let's say the
commercial world or the corporate world
in terms of filmmaking and they
they will tell me that they're envious
of me because i you know i've
shot some features and tv shows but then
something will come their way
some you know low budget feature and
they'll say no because the pay
is no good but then they get frustrated
that they're not getting a feature but
they
just want and narrative pays worse than
commercials that's generally the rule
and
that's for me ignoring the money and
just
chasing the project or the director
has served me very well some of the best
some of the jobs you know i think about
the last show i shot was penn 15 a hulu
series
and that director we've worked together
on multiple
projects we shot a series before for cso
which is a defunct
uh streaming service and
we did we shot a web series for
i think it was like three days four days
of shooting
i think i got paid 100 bucks and i
worked my butt off
and still to this day it's one of my
favorite things that i shot
uh i believe for him he got his
his manager from that he had a screening
it went very well
he it kind of kicked things off for him
and
you know at the time when he asked me to
do it i did hesitate i was like oh
that barely pays like it's barely paying
me anything
and then i did it and i loved it i loved
the project i love everybody involved
a lot of those people are doing well
these days and
it's a piece of my community in los
angeles came from that
tiny web series so for me
and you know we'll see now we're we're
in a pandemic as we speak and i haven't
worked in months
and i have i was
okay with it for a time and now the
anxiety's starting to creep in
but you know i've been freelance for 15
years and
i'm used to all manner of ups and downs
and i keep my overhead low
so that i i don't have to chase
money i guess yeah were you actively
looking for jobs or because
so much of the film industry just
completely shut down
so yeah now i'm i
at this point i have the only thing that
i've done
to be proactive really is i have
i i'm not very active with social media
and
i realize that for my job i probably
should i should make that a higher
priority and i do have friends who are
really good with instagram specifically
uh
and i realize that it's
at least potent has the potential to be
a good tool for finding work
and so i am now trying to treat it
a little more seriously and
trying to create posts that i would like
to see
like maybe a little educational or
behind the scenes or how did you light
this
or why is the the color palette this
that kind of thing so i'm trying to now
just so i feel proactive because i don't
really know
what else i can be doing right now to
find work
uh i've built a decent network over the
years
i have a reputation that i
am proud of but
when people aren't calling i'm
genuinely not sure of what one does uh
and i'm learning i'm trying to figure it
out i'm talking to
different people and seeing what what
they think and
you know just kind of trusting that
something will come and
you know the the last show i shot did
well in terms of
it's it's reviews and and fine finding
an audience
uh so i'm hoping that that you know
might
might put my name on some lists but the
truth is
so much of this is a crapshoot i really
don't know
how to find work even when you know a
decade ago
i woke up every day and i would start on
craigslist and
mandy was a thing and but
i was trying to do that the other day i
was like i'm curious are people posting
jobs no during all this but i've never
been sure how to
find work i've nev it's never made sense
to me
uh but i have been okay at building
relationships
and not in an aggressive networking way
i don't think it's mostly i'm a big film
nerd and i end up bonding with people
who
are also film nerds and the directors
who i've bonded with
it tends to be somebody who i met
somewhere
and we just got to talking about some
movie that we saw and then it snowballs
you're like oh have you ever seen this
movie and this
and just the excitement of it and and i
think that's one of the arguments for
being in los angeles
is you are around other people who are
chasing the same
dream and a lot of them
you'll find people who are nerdy in the
same way you're nerdy
and then you bond and then going back to
what i was saying earlier about
how you are on set that often starts
way before it you know it could be in a
job interview
but ideally it's a social setting you're
meeting a friend of a friend of a friend
set somebody's birthday and you're like
oh
i really liked that person i was like
what do they do oh
cinematographer well you know we have
this thing coming up and
i think that's how a lot of los angeles
connections get made
and i think that was the downside of
going to such a small school is it
really didn't i came to la with zero
connections
and i think people who go to usc for
instance
which is way more expensive so
it has that downside but i think you are
meeting people who are going to be
in the industry for the next decade at
least
and i think that gives you a real head
start in a lot of ways
and now i don't know in terms of film
education and the debt or
all that i don't know pros and cons but
uh i think yeah meeting peop which
again in a pandemic is tricky i have no
idea how i'm gonna
meet people but you know there are film
groups that are meeting on zoom and i
should maybe
try to be more proactive about that but
yeah
and you know doing something like this
who knows who knows who will
who will see the interview and be like
hey
that guy yeah yeah exactly i want to
meditate in my car with you yeah
exactly right so yeah you never know but
yeah yeah i
i i've never been good at figuring out
how to get work how to summon work
it's definitely one of the we i'm i'm
fond of saying this
but i think it's true i'm i'm bad at the
business side of the business
so i see a lot of true artists are that
way
yeah i've definitely i know a lot i have
a lot of musician friends and
some of the best ones are terrible at
every other part of life you know yeah
so yeah i don't know what one does with
that but
yeah you just kind of trust and
i think i think really the fact that
i've been freelanced for so long
and i've gone through such lean times
uh it prepares you for
future lean times so yeah so so far i
feel okay
i think i think i told myself i'm
allowed to get anxious
next march one year at the one year
anniversary
if i still have no work then i'm allowed
to start getting a little anxious
20 21 20 21 yeah so
so i'm a little ahead of schedule i got
anxious for the first time a week or two
ago
so i've gotta that's not part of the
deal so i've gotta i've gotta
keep my because i know as soon as i end
up on a set and i'm on week four
and i'm exhausted i'll be like ah
remember when it was a pandemic
and i could just sleep whenever i wanted
so i'll be wishing for this down time
yeah right well i mean if we look if we
go back to 1918
for was it the the spanish family yeah
so i mean what was that
two years if you look at the chart
not exactly sure but yeah and if you
think about medical advances are far
greater now but then there's the whole
thing does anybody want to take a
vaccine
we don't you know we won't go down that
slipper state but
so i know that's the thing when you're
talking about 2009
and and station fire and all that that
was there was a recession
and that was tragic and we thought we'd
probably never see anything like that in
our lifetime again
and now you add a bad economy to
a communicable disease sorry i can't
even say the word but
that you know is so it's it's there's
new variables that you've never really
been in this
yeah yeah no and you know i will say i
mean
i think that's always on the table i
think you know life is change
and if as soon as you think you have
stability
and a predictability to your life i
think something's gonna
shake it up that's something and that
could be the fire speaking
uh but that's that's how certainly i try
not to take anything for granted
or assume i think also you know the film
industry
in and of itself like the number of
projects
that i was getting ready to shoot that
then just fell through
i mean it's innumerable the i was
supposed to be shooting a feature this
summer that i was really excited about i
had three features lined up this year
and poof you know but i've just
in normal times that still happens
so i think being prepared for
instability
uh in this industry is really important
and you know and
weighing if that's worth it you know i
i'm
lucky i don't have a wife and kids
and so my anxiety any anxiety that
arises is just for me
i would imagine for somebody with a
family
you have to provide for like that's
that's i don't see how that couldn't
raise your stress so you know it's a uh
our industry is pretty cruel it's it
chews you up it spits you out
there's always somebody behind you in
line so
i you know i don't know i think that's
why you you really gotta love it
because otherwise do not recommend
getting into this industry
uh it's and but i'm lucky because i do
love it i love it i love it very
purely so now we'll see how long that
lasts i'm sure one morning i'll wake up
and be like
i'm gonna go see if there's work at the
gas station like who knows
or you could you said you love like
ventriloquism and things like that you
never know you might
make a line of these puppets or what i
mean
there's new things that could happen
that sometimes we don't even know what
our interests are
it's true yeah you never know and again
and i try to be open to all those things
to
life is change and it's all an adventure
and
you know tick-tock who knows how much
time you got left so
i think being open to any any other
experiences any other uh
paths that that reveal themselves in
life like
i don't know take it why not what the
heck
so yeah i'm always open to to anything
that might come down the pike
if i respond to it that's that's all i
need and then i'll follow that
when you look back at those times when
you know you were trying to find work
and and they were lean times did you
lose faith in yourself did you ever say
you know what i should have
i should have done pre-med hmm yeah i
think in my leaner times
there were certainly doubts that came up
like is this plausible i mean the truth
is i still
wonder is can i do this for another 10
20 30 40 years and i genuinely don't
know
um so
i think there have there have been
doubts in terms of
is this is this a a lifestyle
that i want to continue pursuing
uh i've i that is probably the bigger
one
i had a year um 2017 which was my first
really busy year
and i shot i i can't remember it was
like 30 40
episodes of half hour various shows half
hour tv
like it was just i went from one show to
the next to the next
i spent six or seven months in
other states shooting and it was good
uh obviously to be shooting i was so
exhausted by the end of the year that i
felt really burnt out and i got freaked
out
that i was like oh no like can i not do
this anymore
and i and i it took me two months to
recover just
sleeping basically for two months i seen
friends
for the first time in a year and
it it was the first time where i got
scared of what
can happen in this industry on the flip
side i was used to being
broke and not having work and that
brought its own anxiety
and then doing 13-hour days
for a full year just ground me down
mentally and physically and then
and so now i when i have the luxury
of of choosing uh jobs
i now pay more attention who am i
working with
is this really something that i feel a
pull toward
uh and trying to weigh you know pros and
cons of everything
because it's yeah i
i really don't know i mean i really have
i am scared of this industry
i've watched it take more talented
people
and spit them out and turn them bitter
and that's something
i'm really worried about i don't i don't
want that
to be the case with me i want to make
sure that i still
love what i'm doing for as long as
possible
uh and you know part of that is
meditation
making sure i know that so going for
evening walks for me
is like a huge thing it calms me down
and all that so
uh when i'm working on set on on a show
i have a lot of strict rules i have
dietary rules and sleep rules that i
follow really closely because of that
one year
i just it was so intense uh
that it freaked me out and now you know
and built so you're taking that
experience and combining it with
years of being broke and having doubts
but always still just kind of okay just
keep working on your craft and
hope i guess hope that something works
out but
yeah i don't know it's it's really it's
it's a
it's all scary when i really think about
this industry
it's it's a tough it's a tough one to
feel
good about unfortunately and i'm hoping
you know who knows this pandemic maybe
i'm hoping it'll turn into
i've heard some shows are switching to
french hours which means instead of a 12
and a half hour day
with a half hour lunch in the middle is
you
you work for 10 hours straight you don't
stop for lunch it's a walking lunch
and i would love that to to go home two
hours
earlier is definitely worth
not sitting down for a half hour for
lunch
but it helps your immune system you know
we're learning more about
what lack of sleep does to your body and
it's not good
so i do hope that you know be it
a certain director or a certain studio
or
whatever it is that quality of life
maybe could move up the list in terms of
priorities
i think that'd be lovely i don't have a
lot of faith in that happening but
i do hope that there's a way to be doing
this
into my well into my 70s and
feel like i'm still taking care of my
life i don't know if that's possible but
you know one can dream
you